[Music]
so much going on with you so much to
discuss such discussions to be had yes
you were married last weekend Congrats
thank you very much there it is that's
it seven million dollars your
honeymooning here yeah oh yeah how does
it feel it feels good it was the best
day of my life
mm-hmm it's nice you know I I finally
lost my virginity which is nice 35 long
years
go I was bad I was really bad at it
practice 35 years is too long to wait
yeah yeah would have been a good idea to
practice a little bit but it was like
five seconds of just
that was the sound you made yeah we're
getting a divorce
yeah okay no no we're not we're not you
know I look I you know I've known you a
while I'd like to send you a gift I
didn't I don't know where you're
registered oh it's pretty
straightforward just go to this website
for this place called Little Caesars
it's a pizza place that's one of like
one of the thousand skinny slices on one
pizza I love that I wish someone would
actually register there what a great
idea I wonder if they would allow it
they would have to restructure
everything in Little Caesars but I write
it would probably kill them that was
this true did Adam Sandler show up at
your wedding I invited Sandler to the
wedding and he did come yeah I was of
course very worried about it because
he's one of the biggest stars on earth
and I was like oh if Sandler comes
everyone and our families it's gonna
hound him and I don't want him to feel
put out but I also really would love him
to come because we were friendly and the
night before he told me he was like all
right I'll calm I'll be there don't
worry about it and the night before I
was getting a drink at the night before
party that we had sort of a hangout the
families and stuff haha and all of a
sudden I just hear Sandler's boys going
like and it's my guy right yeah I look
up and he's dressed as his character
from that's my boy with like the wig and
a ponytail
like the crappy tie right and I'm like
Woody's is me Danny burger
no he fully committed wholly committed I
was like oh I can't believe you're doing
this to some girl he's like Oh am i
embarrassing you buddy
married everybody and I was like it why
was I worried about Sandler for the rest
of the weekend people kept coming up to
me being like see who's just handed my
table for like an hour and talk to me
about my upstart business yeah yeah it's
a very very nice fellow the best he's so
nice